et c'est une tasse parce que ça cogite
habitude d'y augmenter squeeze ont
surtout aujourd'hui pour la suite de mon
vieux slip qui sera terne épisode parce
que ces derniers souvenirs on va enfin
savoir ce qui se passe à la fin est ce
que ce bébé frei pourrait garder
différente de celle ci je ne sais pas
c'est parti alors depuis talent
j'entends des bruits un peu un peu
glauque des genres de la limitation à
leur écoute et voilà qu'est ce que c'est
je n'en sais rien ça c'est un placard en
tout cas est-ce qu'on va recroiser la
femme forestière qu'est ce que c'est que
ça what
quel est l'intérêt de déjà faut que
j'aille là-bas pour déverrouiller est
rentré dedans je pense à comment on peut
aussi prendre bahdja faut tomber
oui parce qu'on a ici à là par contre
beaucoup je pense pas pour tomber à
paulhan ce bébé a des jambes en métal
voilà les chaises et tabourets dans le
nouveau dlc et découvrez les caisses en
bois parcours d'eric entre baby ce titre
de jeu est déjà beaucoup trop long ok on
y est et voilà qu'est ce que j'avais dit
aux déverrouille au haut des moutons
génial ce qui vient de se passer et je
suppose qu'on monte dessus et qu'on va
là bas non
j'ai fait tomber un truc j'ai fait
tomber un truc ce que ça fait tout
s'écroule de là à temps j'ai juste fait
tomber deux bouteilles d'eau là on se
calme bon bah écoute et on marque on va
passer hop au nom à plus tard ses plats
fameux forestière c'est quoi alors un
merde ça sent mauvais même si c'est le
café ça je suis carrément tcd les deux
professeurs xavier où êtes vous où
êtes-vous non parce que je vois une
l'homme qui vole je sais que c'est vous
alors montrez vous donc ce monde
s'appelle professeur xavier
voilà surtout que le pouvoir de
professeur xavier c'est pas du tout la
télékinésie mais on s'en fout on va dire
que c'est quoi un professeur vous avez
le bronze 1 1 à [ __ ] mais regardez
quoi actuellement il m'aide à faire le
pont et qu'elle n'arrive pas à ce que
c'est que ça un cadeau c'est quoi o o
c'est un piège c'est un piège c'est sur
ces pièces vides en fait je me suis
complètement fait avoir quand faut y
aller faut y aller tu ai dit c'est
professeur xavier professeur et sa
vieille dame approche toi t'es dit à
pouvoir lui aussi il fait de la lumière
qu'est ce que c'est que ça eh bien oui
c'est tout alors c'est allant de bexar
je t'interdis de sauter comme dans
l'intro de pixar je dois aller ici ou
pas du tout je veux aller ou pas du tout
répondre à ma question je vais
terrifiant oui par la keynote d'accord
bon bah merci pour l'indication parce
que je sens elle à colorier ou
d'hambourg où je me casse pourrait
devoir sauter dans le vide
[ __ ] regarder ressemble à ça le
nouveau monstre à la position finale
un monstre qui chassent un mec ouvre une
boîte avec des poissons colombo j'en
sais rien mais la sortie que tu avais
raté le bloc c'est bon je suis débloqué
ok bon on va arrêter de parler en
chuchotant c'est par la kenyane cible
partie de fléchettes avec le monstre je
ne pense pas dans ton d'hollande
ah non il ya des vêtements ça aux places
a amorti sauvegarde non je n'aime pas ça
je n'aime pas ça talent a indiqué qu est
ce qui va m'arriver
alors je vais devenir un as nickel
lorsque vous tenez un objet utilisé vous
avec moi pour le jeter
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre là-dedans il
faut trouver un truc c'est ça n'en sera
pas de chaussettes donc voila voila la
cible à ta dah ok et futur joueur de
baseball nickel hop là on s'enferme
qu'on s'enferme on s'en faire plus tard
la place saloperie j'ai dérangé tout le
monde et ne me sourit pas hello le
croissant va lui salué dans mon
inventaire c'est évident au plus tard
je n'ai pas les mots alors du coup
là-bas falloir trouver un autre objet
une étoile il faut à l'étoile est là bas
est là bas elle va là et je propose ou
là pourquoi ce bruit tu entends quel est
ce bruit ah bah non mais tu es tu
il ya une connexion il ya un truc on est
relié enfin jeu au delà sa faim l'amener
là bas hop
ah c'est ça qui bloque c'est quoi c'est
encore coincés voilà on peut retourner
en arrière et m'empêchera pas d'aller au
sommet de cette étagère
car je suis un grand aventurier bébé
mais mes grands aventuriers quand même
c'est parti on va voir les toiles et
toile vient thanou un [ __ ] mais attend
et enfin marathon ou quoi pour aller
vous trouvez une étoile c'est la cuisine
un regard des fauches août et il faut
shooter là la bouteille achetée avec des
fruits en plus à se cacher c'est bon
mais déjà des arêtes assiette
hpq l'idée c'est parti pour l'idée du
siècle il est du siècle à la voilà
l'idée du siècle d'avoir monté sur le
four appui crois que c'est un sauna et
se mettre bien avec teddy pour enfin
monter sur ce tiroir et prendre cet
objet à on retrouve l'homme cassé en
deux au final n'aura jamais vu un
professeur xavier je suis un peu déçu
c'est que ça le dessin qu'est-ce qu'il
dit ok des choses que je n'ai pas envie
de savoir frappe hutin
non mais n'avait d'armé disc jockey
belge me reste comme ça voilà je fais
doha au danger jambes est vraiment
courageux et maintenant droite ou gauche
eux le dans le seau voilà c'est une
alternative à d'accord c'est en fait
c'est des pièges
si je fais tomber ça y'a une bouteille
qui tombe ça fait du bruit il vient mais
il super forme 2d qui fait débat mais
attention la porte regardez si jamais
j'ouvre trop vos de l'apport bim-sa non
mais attendez ça va là donc d'après ce
dessin le monde fait 123 fois ma taille
dao
c est une lampe oui bravo lucas et ça
c'est une chaise oui aussi
alors je vais voilà merci teddy un de
m'éclairer sans toi jouer a ajouté 22
bouteille
on a vu professeur xavier mais dans les
yeux quoi je pense qu'il a dégagé 1 à
tuer dégagé on m'a demandé bon tu as
fuck c'est quoi ce bruit je me suis
coupé c'est bon t'as tes de piété demain
et tout petit bébé
on a trouvé la fracture sur tout le
corps à l'etac et maintenant le souvenir
le sou oui moi aussi je annonay en fait
tu veux pas me faire un câlin à chis tu
poses un truc et mais qu'est ce que
c'est
quoi tu ne sais pas ce qu'est un
éléphant je suis plus grand des animaux
à faut que des places ça ah non mais je
peux pas taillé du moins il faut que je
monte dessus ça c'est quelque chose de
sûr déjà que des adultes ont un peu de
mal à dépasser une commode
un bébé de deux mois qu'est ce qui tu
veux qu'il fasse et saluer les phares
aux tu as peut-être besoin d'une séance
de bronzage intensif à l'espace on a le
dernier souvenir vite passée par là ça
s'est débloqué j'entends chanter
maintenant j'arrive je chante moi aussi
blabla sa maman si tu permets juste
quelques instants le temps que
professeur xavier et se calme un peu
près des portes alors que la fin juste
devant nous quoi
cours dans le tuyau monga qu on va taper
une petite pièce tour ils sont c'est bon
non non il a vraiment fait non non non
et titi titi à témoin construit en
pleurant et mamans elles viennent
chercher s'il te plaît non super on a le
bras de teddy qui va sûrement pas nous
aider je suis ou l'abattoir et je suis
dans les abysses du jeu quoi oh mon dieu
ok donc les spots vont s'allumer au fur
et à mesure et petits cailloux prix de
bic et c'est quoi ces pop prince et dans
lesquels vous avez trop de possibilités
pas maintenant maman pas maintenant ma
chérie maman à toi maman maintenant
maman spatule en souffre et j'ai dit pas
maintenant oh non mais c'est elle en
fait
en fait j'ai peur de ma mère nantes soit
ça je maman une journée très difficile à
ramer regarder le va jouer ailleurs je
veux juste encore un dernier
il ne nous séparera pas et basse en moi
du noir si tu n'es pas ça je m'écoute
pas alors je vais me fâcher est-ce que
c'est clair et maintenant c'était ces
derniers flash non mais pourquoi donc da
il va s'avérer quelque chose un jour
[ __ ] mais est ce que c'est pour hâter
d'où est ce que ca ça va non mais non
mais on peut pas on peut pas y aller
santé dit qu'on n'a pas le droit on n'a
juste pas le droit des mois qu'il aidé à
nous comme d'habitude a tracé le point
fr non elle aimait l'éléphant date faith
qui la coi pour ferme
non j'ai esquivé bah oui pour le dernier
coach va permettre de me faire une bosse
au front
amedi peut pas mettre assis bien sur wii
dans mon inventaire j'ai la patate aider
s'il vous plaît faut que j'apprenne à
pattes
pas du tout voilà un peu plus éclairé ce
qu'on a pu teddy qu'est ce qui a donc
ouvert ses portes hier tandis que les
amis c'est un grand moment convient de
sous-ensembles
je veux savoir qu est ce que c est donc
tout cinéma
ils sont tous là pour moi tiens je te
caresse un petit coup jeunes éléphants
voilà ça te fait plaisir teddy il est
dans le coffre peut être un [ __ ] il
faut que j'en ai rien dit si c'est sûr
regardez tout ce qui était dans mon rêve
on le retrouve là quoi le croissant de
lune le hibou qui faisait contrepoids
sur le truc lui aussi on l'a vu l'étoile
mais il ya tout tout est là on déménage
regardez les pièces du puzzle bon enfin
je vais arrêter de rien et la chaise
alors stop au final il ya dit est dit
une maman quoi j'ai tout perdu quoi oh
c'est quoi ce délire
oui maman d'avoir scellé bouteille du
dernier monstre tient pas tarder
teddy ne t'approche pas de moi excuse
moi je ne voulais pas faire ça
au nom donc en fait depuis début le
monde c'est la mère qui en fait est une
alcoolique et qui toquent oui c'est mon
père qui vient de sauver c'est ça non
pas du tout
dites moi tout un
bonjour ma petite puce vient ici tu es
en sécurité avec moi tu as aimé ton
cadeau et son bras qu'est ce qui lui est
arrivé ne t'en fais pas on va le soigner
d'accord donc c'est lui qui m'avait
offert mon petit ours wahaha c'était
super beau comme fin c'était génial
3 je déménageais vraiment mais avec mon
père en fait bon ben on à la foire de
bombes the slip j'espère que ce business
plaît vous aura plus ces cas n'hésitez
pas vu la vidéo ça fera vraiment plaisir
ou à le dire en commentaire ou enfin
juste que je sache savoir si je fais
d'autres l'espèce sur d'autres jeux
personnellement c'est un truc que je
faisais jamais avant et en fait je
découvre tout simplement que j'adore ça
on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo tu as tout le monde
appuie ce deuxième sauvetage
troisième sauvetage alors pas de
quatrième
[Musique]
c'est